foreign
hello everyone I'm Gerald from Geek
culture and today we'll be checking out
the Diablo 4 collectors edition let's
send this over to us I played the game
quite a lot over the weekend over three
days played hardcore and today I'll be
checking out all the items we'll be
getting in this box itself this is one
of the heaviest boxes and collectors
editions we've ever opened but let's
look at the site itself you can see this
is the Diablo 4 symbol and then let's
turn it around to the back to see what
we have himself I'm not sure if these
will ever be sold in store but it's
massive guys it's very big it's very
heavy uh kind of creation that's one of
the first things that we have a called
mouse pad we go to a cloth map or
Century pin of the horror dream art
prints two of them and a Diablo 4
collectors edition art book and I
noticed something very small here there
are blue phone not included as well the
game this is a box with no game inside
you guys who have gotten it buy a
digital copy instead
okay and hopefully this opens up very
nicely opening up the gates of hell
oh okay
wow okay the art print came out let's
leave it there looking good like this
this is the first art print
I think it could be used as a displayed
very nice it actually comes with a
normal frame itself we have a ticket
we'll take a closer look and do that As
We Lay it all out first
so we've got the art prints here
the second are print here with Lilith
and inarios daddy and mommy having a
fight and we are all caught in the
middle what the heck symbols are
probably lift and in areas opens up
really nicely
and let's put her down okay there's very
nice tabs here you can pull up so you
don't have to really dig your fingers in
and record the art book as well let's
look in there this art book is amazing
this actually makes up most of the
weight of the book I'm pretty sure man
oh what is nice that's it but that was
the back looking way hold the back how
does the back look like
but this is pretty nice if you guys have
watched the cinematics you know the
develop budget went into like the final
cinematic itself it's all split up by
according tool it seems to be according
to each Zone from Sanctuary
yeah very nice okay let's open up let's
see what other Treasures we have here
are you guys ready
wow
right yeah
okay this is a nice touch he opens up
from the side no you put it out with
that yeah show it for the camera
then I'll flip it to the front like this
to be careful
I will remove this strap here
again let's look at the Box something
funny that I realized well this game is
called Diablo most of the game is
actually focused on in areas
and Lilith this is the Box itself we see
more of their motifs in our assemble
here and little leaves a symbol as well
before we continue thanks visit for
sending this over to us this channel is
supported by Brands who help us improve
our content and keep us going so stay
around for this sponsored message meet
the cyborg 15 gaming laptop from MSI
check out his translucent material
design that not only looks good but
feels good thanks to its Ultra
lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12 gen
Intel Core i7 HD series processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and they
immersed with its the hibic twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com you ready for this
let's open up
to see how he looks like
whoa oh what's that okay there's
batteries inside so it comes with
batteries this is the candle I'm sure
okay this is substantially weighty as
well it's not light it's actually pretty
dense you can see that it is live here
to the front
and you've got innerence as well and
it's only one singular candle so I guess
that if you really want to have two
gotta buy two characters additions guys
if you can afford it we're going to pop
this in with the batteries later on to
give you a closer look and to see how it
actually pans out and our final piece I
think here is where we get all the cloth
maps all the goodies
yeah so really The Horizon print and
it's not just the pin itself I think the
display and how they have actually
presented it is very very nice
there's something inside the box over
there right something said that boxer
says something in this box
no it doesn't seem like
it's up here
no there's nothing in this box let's
open up this is like magical man it's
like Christmas morning
oh okay finally we have the cloth map
of sanctuary or part of sanctuary or the
place that we've been playing okay let's
open it up to see how it actually all
goes spoilers guys you have not played
um you might want to look away but this
is very nicely weted and old okay let me
let me open up drop like this do you
have enough length yeah I believe so
okay one two three whoa
yeah it looks like three actually don't
think so yeah huh yeah but it's a hole I
mean the whole Century in New York right
yeah so is this how Century looks like
but in the game itself right we look at
it something like this yeah more like
that it is because we got uh fracture
piece where you start off with over here
they hold up the Scots Glen the dry
steps
um and this is the later part x five and
four this is the first main town that
everyone goes to and uh if you play long
enough I think this is one of the best
towns everything's very nicely close
together once you pop out yeah
but here you go this is the map of
sanctuary okay
and let me lay this down
let me show you what's on the reverse
side nothing much on reverse but it's
very nicely worth it honestly yeah very
nicely with it and finally
we have a mouse mat simple nothing too
fancy itself but I think everything else
compared to this I'm wondering why they
let us open this for last but maybe it's
down to really how simple it is the
design nothing too fancy but I think it
works the candle let's go and check out
the candle right now let's go over this
in detail we've got a lift the mother of
sanctuary very good details here this is
solid by plastic but very hard plastic
by the way you don't think you can
really see it from the brushing itself
and we've got in areas here looking
really really fancy they're both back to
back to each other the cam the candle
here is solid as well and this is a
small little plastic flame let's put in
the batteries and see how it actually
goes thanks blizzard for even sending
this over we will actually is included
so we don't have to run out to get them
you put them in here
oh and it's on ready is there on and off
switch even it should be right
I don't think so okay
small little flame
you can see that it is a very little
flicker there's a small little flicker
that we have
very subtle
oh maybe this one ah oh my God
okay the on and also is here it's on uh
it's the emblem on uh in area so you
just press this that's how it goes let
me show you for the camera
and throw
so comparing to say his art piece here
putting the left one here you can see
that is this symbol here is actually the
light switch for the
candle all right okay let's lay this all
out nicely for you guys to take a look
get a good close-up of all the
individual items uh let me show you the
show the camera once again you start off
with a very nice art prints you have
the battle not so much the battle I have
in hell but just hell and all these
people
this crazy folks
the next thing that you open up is the
art book
very heavy and substantial art book I
think fans of the game and art will love
this so much we've got a horizon print
print pin horror pin
no green pin great for your cosplay
efforts it is a solid plastic pin not
metal opening up we got them with all
these petals that came along with it
they've got the mouse pad
and I think this is something that is
really really cool let's do this one
more time for the camera and then we'll
see the map of sanctuary
[Music]
yeah
very fancy and lastly
this massive candle witty guys this
thing can be used as a weapon no joke
it's magnetic guys whoa whoa whoa I
didn't realize this right here
there's a bit of resistance yeah
this is a solid box
nice
and there we have it this is the
collector's edition of Diablo 4 very
impressive thanks blizzard for sending
this over to us and I think we really
appreciate it and find a nice spot of
all these items in our office let me
know your thoughts do you think this is
worth it let me know in the section
below this is Gerald from Geek culture
really appreciate it and if you found
this video helpful remember to like
share and subscribe it really does go a
long way and if you want to see more
stuff check this out
[Music]
foreign